mit dem zug in die tschechische
hauptstadt prag ist die erste etappe des
interrail abenteuers von aidan gibson
aus edinburgh von den fassaden in der
altstadt bekommt der student kaum genug
und natürlich ist auch die berühmte
karlsbrücke aus dem vierzehnten
jahrhundert ein absolutes muss
[Musik]
manches erinnert an gibson dabei an
seiner heimatstadt in schottland
wir haben auch jede menge musik und
künstler auf den straßen viele
veranstaltungen aber prag ist völlig
anders nicht sogar schöner als ich
erwartet hatte
die gebäude sind unglaublich wenn man
sie mit eigenen augen sind es hat sich
wirklich gelohnt herzukommen dass er das
erleben kann hat er einen kostenlosen
interrail ticket zu verdanken
dafür musste er sich mit seiner
geplanten reiseroute bewerben und ein
europa quiz beantworten eine jury wählte
dann 15.000 gewinner aus alle genau 18
jahre alt und eu-bürger der schotte
sieht sich in der pflicht
[Musik]
ibm besseres wissen quasi botschafter
dieses programm
hoffentlich wird es dass viele jahre
geben denn ich glaube es kann einiges
bewirken
ich werde meine erfahrungen in sozialen
netzwerken teilen und vielleicht sogar
vorträge halten
das ist eine menge ja ich bin ein
botschafter
juli interrail ist eine initiative von
martin sperr und vincent immanuel herr
die beiden berliner haben bei der
brüsseler eu-kommission für das
gratisticket gekämpft sie träumen davon
dass jeder eu bürger zum achtzehnten
geburtstag ein intervall ticket
geschenkt bekommt das europäische
zugticket zum pauschalpreis gibt es
schon seit 1972 jugendliche die auf
grenzenlosen schienen europa erkunden
können besser dabei helfen vorurteile
abzubauen als manche politiker diese
überzeugung gewannen die zwei
initiatoren natürlich bei einer eigenen
interesse schlüsselereignis auf dieser
reise und besondere erlebnisse beim die
gastfreundschaft die uns begegnet dass
leute die uns zum essen eingeladen haben
nach hause eingeladen haben wo wir von
einer stadt wie under gereist sind und
leute bescheid gesagt haben dass wir
kommen und diese ganz engen fielen neun
verbindungen freundschaften die wir
geknüpft haben das war wirklich europa
für uns und wir haben europa wirklich
mit neuen augen kennen gelernt und
wirklich verstanden dass europa nicht
gesetze sind oder irgendwie politische
union sondern die menschen in all ihrer
vielfalt
viele der 15.000 jugendlichen berichten
in den sozialen medien von ihren
erlebnissen und begegnungen quer durch
europa doch schlägt das wirklich neue
brücken
kritiker werfen ein es nütze nichts wenn
junge menschen auf ihrem interesse die
unterschiedlichen biersorten probieren
würden
[Musik]
gibson hat sich vorgenommen auch die
geschichte der länder zu erkunden die er
bereist im prager kommunismus museum
erfährt er viel über die entstehung der
tschechoslowakei und das spätere bündnis
mit der sowjetunion der kommunismus in
der tschechischen republik ist
geschichte
allerdings auch bald die
eu-mitgliedschaft schottlands nachdem
rexit wird kein brite mehr ein free
interrail ticket bekommen können
[Musik]
ich glaube viele menschen haben blind
abgestimmt und sind irgendeiner
propaganda gefolgt wie im kommunismus
und dann muss es doch mal bier geben
ausgerechnet im heimatland des pilsener
scans zu probieren wäre schade
[Musik]
für elton gibson endet nach zwei tagen
die prager etappe interrail das ist eine
art speeddating mit europa kaum hat man
einen ort näher kennengelernt geht es
auch schon weiter zum nächsten und das
oft ganz allein was der 18 jährige
jedoch mag man trifft leichter andere
die auch solo reisen
daraus können leichter freundschaften
entstehen alleine reisen das kann ich
wirklich empfehlen
gibsons nächste stationen sind wien
budapest und ljubljana zwei wochen durch
vier europäische länder
bevor es mit vielen neuen eindrücken
zurück nach schottland geht